Hi ihr Lieben!
Wir machen heute einen Blätterteig-Kranz einfach weil ich mir gedacht habe:
perfekt zum Grillen! Da muss man ja auch immer was mitbringen
- also man "muss" nicht aber man nimmt halt gerne was mit -
(H: Man sollte!)
Man sollte wenn man eingeladen ist oder wenn man
selber grillt dann - also ich persönlich hab das immer gern, dass man noch so kleine Schmankerl hat,
dann greift man sich hier was und da was!
Und das kommt jetzt nicht auf den Grill. Ihr könntet auch Blätterteig grillen
aber macht's ruhig gerne auch im Ofen und bereitet das vor. Also ein Blätterteig-Kranz, den ich heute fülle
mit einer Spinat-Käse Füllung. Also ich nehme Fetakäse,
ich entscheide sogar spontan, ob ich noch Gouda mit dazu nehme weil ich hab letztens auch Börek
mit Fetakäse und Gouda gemacht, hat mir auch sehr gut geschmeckt.
Aber ich starte jetzt zuallererst mal und zwar habe ich hier Blätterteig.
Das ist Tiefkühl-Blätterteig, der ist ja dann immer so rechteckig.
Ihr könntet auch den aus der Kühltruhe nehmen aber ich habe immer tiefgekühlten da.
So, den lege ich mir jetzt hier auf mein Schneidebrett und schneide ihn einmal diagonal durch.
Dann habe ich zwei Dreiecke und das mache ich jetzt so mit den anderen Blätterteig...Blättern?
Blätterteig-Blättern?
(H: *kichert*)
Auf jeden Fall mache ich das jetzt und dann zeige ich euch wie ihr das schichtet,
da nehme ich heute nämlich mein Pizzablech aber ihr könnt auch z.B.
so den Springform-Boden nehmen, fällt mir gerade so ein.
Aber das zeige ich euch gleich.
(H: Und die genauen Mengenangaben?)
Die genauen Mengenangaben findet ihr immer in der Videobeschreibung, danke für's Erinnern!
Weil da fragen auch immer viele nach aber die sind bei mir immer in der Videobeschreibung.
Es soll ein schnelles Rezept sein, es ist schönes Wetter draußen, ihr sollt hier nicht so lange in der Küche stehen.
das muss jetzt einfach ruck-zuck gehen! Und jetzt habe ich hier tiefgekühlten Spinat
einfach komplett auftauen lassen. Falls der euch sehr wässrig sein sollte, dann versucht das so ein bisschen
wegzunehmen, bei mir geht's jetzt hier. Das ist übrigens Rahmspinat, das würde auch mit normalem Spinat
oder auch mit frischem funktionieren. So und da gebe ich jetzt einmal Gewürze dazu.
Salz ein bisschen, oh Moment...
(H: Aber deine Schürze, die ist so verknickt! Mach die mal grade! Mensch!)
So?
(H: Ja!)
Tschuldigung!
(H: Nein, weiter, das ist immernoch...*lacht*)
So?
(H: Ja, jetzt! Sonst kommen wieder Kommentare: "Ist Kiki schwanger?")
Jaa, das sind die Corona..die Corona Pfunde!
(H: *kichert*)
So, ein bisschen Muskatnuss, nicht viel, nur ein bisschen. Das passt immer richtig richtig gut zum Spinat.
So, das war's schon. Und Curry, ich mag immer Curry im Spinat. Ich mag das total gerne! So!
Da gebe ich jetzt Fetakäse mit dazu, einfach reinbröseln.
Und ich mach das, ich mache das! Ich gebe auch ein bisschen Gouda noch mit dazu gleich.
(H: Und was macht der Gouda da drin dann?)
Einfach Geschmack!
Und dann zieht sich das auch so ein bisschen.
(H: Ach dann zieht sich das! Oh, okay!)
Ohh!
Ein bisschen Pfeffer habe ich ganz vergessen. Frisch gemahlener Pfeffer schmeckt so gut!
So, jetzt wird die Füllung einfach verteilt.
So, ich klappe das jetzt hier ein.
Besser ist's wenn ihr dann den überstehenden Blätterteig einfach unten reinstopft
so ein bisschen versteckt, dann kann euch das auch nicht aufgehen und -
also ich muss ja sagen: Wie lange haben wir bis jetzt gebraucht Hamza? Realistische Einschätzung?
(H: 7 minuten? 5 Minuten? Weiß ich nicht!)
Also ich hätt's jetzt auf 3 Minuten geschätzt.
(H: Okay!)
Du schätzt immer anders als ich, das kommt unauthentisch rüber! Das kommt so unauthentisch!
(H: Weißt du wieso? Weil ich das aufnehmen muss, deswegen dauert's bei mir länger im Kopf.)
Okay, wir machen einfach nochmal.
Also Hamza was glaubst du: Wie lange hat das jetzt gedauert bis hierhin?
(H: Also äh...3-4 Minuten?)
Ja, 3-4 Minuten!
(H: Ja)
Also das ist ein schnelles Rezept! Ich mache das jetzt - also das könnte jetzt auch direkt in den Backofen,
ich hab's nur noch mit Eigelb bestrichen.
Ich mache da jetzt ein bisschen Sesam drauf weil ich find das sieht einfach immer schön aus
Schwarzkümmel würde auch passen aber ich bleib heute nur bei Sesam.
Und dann backe ich das bei 200° C Ober- und Unterhitze im vorgeheizten Backofen bis es schön goldbraun ist.
Das kann so 20-25min dauern und dann können wir das warm essen.
Ohh ich freu mich!
So, komm!
Also der Blätterteig-Kranz ist schnell gemacht, schmeckt sehr gut, knusprig
und mir schmeckt er am besten warm. Ihr könnt ihn aber auch noch kalt genießen.
Also ihr müsst mir jetzt auch noch einen Gefallen tun:
ihr müsst mir am liebsten in die Kommentare schreiben, was ihr jetzt zum Sommer sehen möchtet.
Also heute zum Beispiel ist es schon richtig warm.
Ich habe auch gerade was mit Sahne gemacht und dann habe ich gemerkt:
Boah, uuuh! Ist schon - also schmilzt schon weg, ne?
(H: Man muss aber sagen: in den nächsten Tagen wird's wieder kälter ein bisschen.)
Es wird wieder kälter aber dann -
(H: Trotzdem für den Sommer...)
Genau, dann wird's glaube ich nächste Woche wieder wärmer.
Also schreibt mir gerne eure Sommerwünsche rein, was ihr sehen möchtet, was realistisch ist.
Natürlich jetzt keine dicke fette Buttercremetorte oder sowas sondern vielleicht Grillrezepte.
Schreibt's mir auf jeden Fall rein, wir lesen uns das gemeinsam durch, ne Hamza?
(H: Ich will wieder ein Burger Rezept von dir sehen!)
Ja, bin ich auch für, dass wir mal wieder ein Burger Rezept machen.
(H: Burger Buns haben wir ja schonmal gemacht.)
Ja, ja und klassische Burger auch. Jetzt fehlen halt so diese abgespacten Varianten, ne?
(H: Ja!)
Das machen wir, das machen wir!
Also auch jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag! Ich hoffe, das Video hat euch gefallen, hinterlasst ein Abo
und wir sehen uns dann wieder bei meinem nächsten Rezept. Tschüss, eure Kiki!